the european super league may have eaten
humble pie this week
but it's these manchester united fans
that are left with the bitter aftertaste
the glazer family which owns united
rarely communicates with fans
but after apologizing this week it
promised to rebuild trust
that was the first time that joe glaser
has communicated with united fans
for 16 years 16 years of nothing
they haven't been to a game since april
2019 they don't care
empty words he said we need to rebuild
trust there was no trust to begin with
because it's not enough i understand
it's more there needs to be systemic
changes
to the way the clubs are earned across
the whole country because it's not just
man united it's not just the glazers
i've been following united since 1956
so you can guess me age it's about time
that somebody spoke up
about the parasites united would have
become one of 12 permanent members of
the ill-fated european super league
a breakaway competition from uefa's
champions league
and joel glaser who is the club's
co-chairman was set to become the new
league's vice chair
the fans here want a 50 plus one
ownership structure which would give
them control of the club
through a voting majority commercial
investors would still be able to make
suggestions
but they'd need the fans backing to get
things done
it's a model that has worked for fans of
germany's bundesliga giants
a man who knows all about the german
model is liverpool manager jurgen klopp
who has backed his club's owners one
thing the supporters here seem to be
happy about
is the investment that the fenway sports
group has put into the club
enabling them at one point to buy what
was the world's most expensive defender
and just a few months after that the
world's most expensive goalkeeper
in today's match day program liverpool's
captain jordan henderson pleaded with
fans not to fall out with the club's
owners
the size of this crowd suggests many of
them are listening
sadia chowdhury sky news